what's going on guys this is rob and as
promised it is sunday so we are starting
secret invasion now the last time we did
this we did it all as one video which
was about 20 minutes long we're actually
going to do this more in depth and we're
just going to kind of break it down
piece by piece over multiple videos so
in this video we're basically going to
discuss how it was that secret invasion
happened in the first place so this may
be familiar territory to a lot of you
guys out there who are familiar with my
channel but what this does is this
initially picks up on tarnax 4 which is
basically the home world or the throne
world of the scrolls now one of the
things that i want to establish right
off the bat some of you guys in your
travels may have heard of a world called
scrollos which is the homeworld of the
scrolls that's where they originated
from so think of it like humanity
originated on earth but we decided to
colonize some other world that exists
out there and then we moved the capital
of our people to like that world that's
basically what happened here but the
important thing is that this takes place
in the aftermath of the cree scroll war
now that was a conflict that had
actually been going on for millions of
years and it has an origin that we're
not going to go into here in this story
uh but the important thing is that the
cree scroll war was effectively ended
really through a combination of
different things that all kind of
happened at the same time the arrival of
captain marvel from mccree the dark
phoenix saga different things like that
but the reality of this is that the
scroll empire is reeling from their
defeat basically facing off against the
cree that was done at the hands of some
of the involvement of people on earth
particularly when it came to earth they
view it as a backwater world and so
because of that it would basically be
like the united states having the
greatest military might in the world
being defeated by people with pitchforks
right it would just be like a huge just
slam to the ego and so what this does is
it leads to a discussion between emperor
dorek and his military on whether or not
they should directly target earth but
fortunately for them earth comes to them
and it comes in the form of the
illuminati now this is technically this
comic recovering right here is
technically the illuminati one shot and
for those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that when the illuminati
were initially introduced into marvel
comics the original one shot story was
actually a story that was part of the
original civil war event and the idea is
that you basically had reed richards you
had iron man name with a submariner uh
blackwell of the inhumans doctor strange
and professor xavier who all came
together in wakanda and black panther
literally told them do not do this it's
not going to work it's going to end up
with calamity uh but they basically came
together in wakanda so they could
operate off the grid and decided that
because the pre-scrolled war had come so
close to destroying the world that
because they all had little pieces of
information xavier dealing with the
phoenix saga the avengers and fantastic
four dealing with marvel that had they
shared that information the conflict
never would have come as close to earth
as it did and so coming together at the
illuminati the idea is that no one's
going to know they exist but they're
always going to keep information shared
and they're going to secretly manipulate
things behind the scenes as you can
probably imagine it ends up disastrous
but the first thing they did was show up
here to the planet of the scrolls and
quite literally like reed richards is
like i came here to tell you that we
will not tolerate another invasion
attempt on earth if you even so much as
approach earth space it will force us to
gather and come to you with manpower
that you could not even imagine and the
response by xavier is like this is a
warning and of course tony stark chimes
in and says do not come here or we will
destroy your people now here's an
important distinction to understand on
earth that can be done some of the most
powerful beings that exist in the
entirety of marvel comics exist on earth
the molecule man who can alter reality
on a multiversal scale he exists on
earth franklin richards who can alter
reality on a universal scale he's from
earth he got all kinds of stuff and
emperor dorak does not take this lightly
but he also won't take it sitting down
and that's one of the things where he's
just kind of like here's the thing to
understand now that you've come here and
you've made that threat to us we weren't
really sure if we were going to invade
your world before we're going to now
like this is not something that i'm just
going to idly sit by and let happen
which makes sense right a man doesn't
walk into another man's house and start
telling him what's what and that's
exactly what's going on here and so as a
result of that the illuminati basically
destroy the vessel that emperor dorek is
sitting on right they just eradicate the
entire vessel itself blow the whole
thing to pieces and fly out in their
spacecraft now of course this leads to
the entire scroll armada just chasing
after them right because while doric
isn't killed trying to assassinate their
leader in that way is no small thing
right that's a massive event and because
it leads to the entire scroll armada
following them one of the things to know
is that while earth has the most
powerful beings in existence it is not
the most technologically advanced place
in the universe the scrolls have been
around for millions of years the create
just as long and so what you're talking
about are people with just the ability
to achieve interstellar travel and the
defensive and offensive capabilities to
go with it but the thing about this is
that because they're so much more
technologically advanced than the
illuminati or really there's anybody on
earth they overtake their ship quite
readily and try as he might iron man
tries to get them out of there but it
ultimately doesn't work and what it does
is it leads to the scrolls basically
taking the illuminati and then analyzing
their individual bodies they basically
go through to try to understand reed
richards now when it comes to the
scrolls and read because guys like uh
like clerk who was the original super
scroll basically a scroll that had all
the abilities of the fantastic four
which was really done more through
science magic than anything else it
basically led to them having involvement
with the fantastic four becoming aware
of reed more than anything else another
particular important thing about reid is
that he's the smartest person in the
universe so literally every race across
the universe knows how capable and
intelligent reed richards is so his
intelligence respected but at the end of
the day the scrolls really function in
the capacity of just trying to figure
out a way to destroy the various
powerful beings that exist on earth more
than anything else and so they're
literally going through and analyzing
each and every one of these guys and
they talk about the nature of them for
example they don't understand how black
volt's vocal cords work right how is it
that he's able to emit a quasi-sonic
scream and one of the discussions by the
science guys is like could we just rip
his vocal cords out and the answer to
this is no if we did that because we
don't know how they work we could
eradicate this entire area where the
throne resides we would kill everybody
here we don't know if that would be the
case or not what's particularly
interesting to them is tony stark
because when they look at everybody else
and they all have powers they look at
xavier and they're like okay so his
powers are tied to his genome right
that's not very difficult now of course
just kind of a sidetrack this story here
and the entirety of secret invasion
takes place before the events of what
are happening right now in marvel comics
which is avengers versus x-men versus
eternals where they're actually changing
the nature of how mutants came into
existence in the first place so um it's
not it's not an important thing for this
story but just kind of clarifying things
for people who are sort of new to marvel
comics in terms of what's going on now
and secret invasion but the thing about
this is that tony stark's really
fascinating to them because he's just a
guy but he has no powers he's just a
dude who wears a metal suit and like
that's it and even to the scrolls tony
stark's star tech his iron man suit is
not that technologically advanced and
that's kind of the funny thing is
because of events like secret invasion
tony stark actually modifies his iron
man suits so they become more advanced
and can actually rival the technology of
other races that exist out there in the
universe it's just one of those
instances where tony stark is always
learning and always improving but the
funny thing about this is that while
tony stark's being held prisoner he's
suddenly rescued by the avengers who
seemingly come out of nowhere now the
funny thing here is we would look at
this and say okay cool the day's saved
but what's really wild about this is
he's like okay so here's the thing about
you guys he's like you guys always
underestimate your opponents it's why
you lost the pre-scrolled war so the
question that i have to ask you here is
how dumb do you really think i am and
this is when we find out it's not the
avengers it's scrolls posing as the
avengers now this is a really really
cool moment because this is kind of the
the precursor to secret invasion and is
sort of setting the stage for like what
the scrolls will eventually end up doing
which becomes incredibly awesome when it
happens but the reality here is that's
when the scrolls kind of start bickering
like i told you this was a bad idea we
never should have tried to do this to
get information now them trying to get
information out of them will be a very
key component to what's going on here
but the thing to understand is that
because tony stark at least with his
combat training is able to overpower
these scrolls it of course allows him to
basically grab some guns start shooting
the place up and start freeing each
member of the illuminati who of course
helps to free the other members as
they're freed themselves and of course
this basically leads to them basically
making their escape here but the problem
here is they're back on the chase trying
to get away from the scroll armada if
they couldn't get away before there's no
reason to believe that they can get away
now the funny thing about this is that
what they end up doing is basically
creating a kind of illusion using a
combination of professor xavier's
telepathic abilities and dr strange's
magic and what they end up doing is
literally casting this illusion of
galactus appearing now there's a reason
why they chose this and i'll talk about
that here in a second here in about one
or two minutes but what this does is it
basically leads to the illuminati making
their escape by way of the galactus
illusion and then in turn we switch back
to the throne world and what we end up
finding out is that they basically got
exactly what they needed what they were
looking for was the ability to duplicate
superheroes they were looking to
understand exactly how their powers
works now the problem with this is that
this project sort of falls slightly to
the wayside it becomes just kind of like
a background science project while the
scrolls are working on rebuilding their
empire but what ends up going on is that
around this time this leads to the
introduction of varenke now in order to
understand varenki we have to do a
little bit of history when it comes to
the scrolls right so the way this works
out is if you guys are familiar with
probably the marvel cinematic universe
or marvel comics or anything like that
you guys are aware that on earth in the
early days of humanity's existence the
celestials visited earth and they
created the eternals the deviants and
then modified the genes of humanity so
that at some future point in time they
would develop powers i.e the origin of
mutants in marvel comics earth was not
the only place they visited and in fact
the scroll homeworld of scrollos way
back when was one of the places they
visited the difference here is that
unlike earth where the eternals and the
deviants engaged in some kind of a war
with humanity sort of being caught in
the middle and then the deviants were
all but just destroyed when they tried
to destroy the celestials when the
celestials arrived on earth for a second
time unlike that when it came to the
scrolls what you had were two people you
had clibben and sligger and i know their
names are really really weird slugert
led the deviant scrolls and cliven led
the eternal scrolls and then you just
had normal scrolls they don't matter and
the reason why is because as soon as the
deviant scrolls came into existence they
eradicated the normal scrolls they were
just totally destroyed and they did it
by literally just pretending to be
normal scrolls and then just
assassinating people every chance they
got and sliggert was the one who led the
entirety of the deviant scrolls now
cleveland was the one who led the
eternal scrolls and once the deviant
scrolls had basically eradicated all the
normal scrolls they killed all but one
of the eternals which was cleben and
what ended up happening is that clipping
actually orchestrated a ceasefire and he
effectively married sligurd and then
they ascended into godhood according to
the stories but the reason why that
matters is because when it came to that
essence that kind of rising to godhood
one of the things that cliven and slight
had done is they had kind of written out
this prophecy that foretold that the
entire nature of the scroll race is that
it's to extend into the universe and
then eventually take over the entirety
of the universe so for the scrolls
themselves they see the universe being
ruled by them as their divine right
right like literally their gods told him
it would happen and so this gave birth
to what's called the dard van which is
basically the religious sect of the
scroll empire it's not purely science
and so because the dard van had always
existed as science began to become more
prominent it began to take a back seat
but varenki is a member of the dard van
she's a member of their religious sect
one of the things that had been
prophesied in addition to the idea that
the scrolls would basically go into
space and conquer the universe is that
at some future point in time the scroll
race itself would be eradicated by what
was called quote unquote a devourer and
then a wave and that's basically what
varenki is talking about here that she
kind of pops back up again and is like
look like with my religious sect behind
me emperor doric you have to listen our
people are going to be destroyed we have
to leave this world right we have to
leave this place right if we don't leave
the prophecy will come true and the
entirety of our people will be destroyed
the issue with this is that it creates a
bit of a civil war where emperor dorec
basically labels varenke as an
insurrectionist and a religious zealot
his people basically conquer and
imprison her people and then essentially
just throw them away on some desert
world where they're basically left to
die and so what this does is it switches
over to the experiment that the scrolls
are conducting with trying to find a way
to successfully duplicate superheroes
and the thing about this is that because
of everything that varenki said it kind
of resonates with emperor dorek and so
what's been going on here is that with
the experiment involving reed richards
who they successfully duplicated what
they do is they literally have these
situations where reed is just kind of
cloned over and over and over again and
each time he's introduced to his family
and his family's so happy to see them
and then they're kind of like you know
tell us about galactus tell us
everything you know about galactus and
the reality is like reed sometimes just
doesn't know anything about galactus or
he doesn't know anything about something
else but the truth is that every time
they clone him he just simply doesn't
have the information that they need
because that information was not carried
over in the cloning process and so these
members of the fantastic four the family
that's here to see read it's just
scrolls impersonating and reid himself
is literally just a clone that's the
whole idea clone superheroes and then
see if they can replace superheroes
using clones now the kicker to all this
and the concern about galactus comes by
way of basically brian michael bendis in
this story invoking a previous story
that was written in 1983 with fantastic
four issue 257 and what ended up going
on here is that in effect galactus
arrived at the throne world of the
scrolls now this is important because
one of the pieces of technology that the
scrolls had was the ability to cloak
their world because it's not the first
time galactus came riding by but it's
not the first time that galactus
appeared near them and the prophecy
being what it is if nothing else they
were always just taking precautionary
measures the reality here is that in
that story they essentially missed their
chance to cloak their world but even if
they had it wouldn't have made any
difference because frankie ray who is
the herald of galactus at the time knows
exactly where the scroll throne world is
and led galactus straight to it so there
was no way for them to hide anyway the
end result being that galactus basically
annihilates the entirety of the throne
world now what was left of the scroll
race which was literally just kind of a
a
military-led hodgepodge of the group
what ended up happening is they just
kind of limped on and then tried to
restore their their race back to
greatness but then annihilation happened
when the villain annihilus led the
annihilation wave across the universe
and almost killed everything and that
all but destroyed what was left of the
squirrel race so all you really had with
regards to the scrolls was basically
just a ragtag bunch of scientists and
the continued attempt to like find a way
to duplicate earth superheroes but this
ultimately leads to the science division
and even those members of the squirrel
race who were still alive reaching out
to varenki and bringing her back from
the desert world where she officially
becomes empress of the scroll race so
for those of you guys who read secret
invasion and you are wondering how she
became the leader during secret invasion
this is exactly how but there's also
major changes that have taken place
major progressions to this project that
simply weren't there before and so one
of the things we find out is that one
their group is basically moved to
tarnac's ten that's their new home world
right tarnac's ex but the other thing is
that varenke is informed by the science
officer of the scroll race that because
of all these advancements they no longer
have to traditionally clone superheroes
the way they did before they don't have
to clone reed richards and then try to
get information out of him instead they
can just use their shape-shifting
technology now one of the big things
here is that when it comes to the
deviant scrolls shape-shifting is one of
their powers the issue is that if a
scroll were to just shape-shift and then
go to earth and then just say hey
everybody i'm tony stark because they're
not actually tony stark and because they
don't know the mannerisms of tony stark
people who know iron man would
immediately pick up on the fact that
it's not actually him kind of a sixth
sense if you want to call it that to say
nothing of telepaths who could read his
mind and immediately know that it's a
scroll and not actually tony stark and
so in order to get around this which
this is a genius maneuver in order to
get around this what the scrolls are
basically doing here at least what they
have been doing is traveling around and
snatching up members of the superhero
community bringing them to the scroll
home world and then basically having
scrolls turn into those guys and one of
the things that they say is they
basically refer to like the newest
scroll they have and we're literally
told this is the model for our new super
scroll though he resembles the physical
attributes of the warrior clerk and his
faux fantastic four powers that was for
the most part scientific trickery this
is the real deal any human or mutant who
we can strip a dna sample of we can now
utterly duplicate their abilities any
mix or match of any kind or if you want
just a hyper-powered reed richards or
ben grimm we can do that too but like
clerk displayed for many years we
believe that a warrior with a mixture of
power attributes reveals itself to be a
much more established threat the more
weapons a warrior has and ultimately the
better they become now that's where
things get really interesting because
again they hit on the idea that they
can't simply just shape-shift that in
order for this invasion to happen in
order for them to literally invade earth
replace superheroes and then essentially
conquer earth which they see earth as
their prophesized new home that a scroll
has to literally become that person that
their mind has to be altered they have
to actually believe that's the case and
so one of the things that ends up
happening and i'm not going to show you
who this person is but one of the things
that ends up happening is that there is
a person who is already on earth who is
a scroll and has been there for quite
some time and has been operating behind
the scenes for quite some time but this
person appearing here and showing up and
basically offering testimony shows that
the project works that the scrolls using
this process can infiltrate earth they
can pretend to be anybody they want to
including a powerful being a person
whose abilities they can copy and they
can do this without any telepath knowing
that they're an actual scroll they can
do it without wolverine or somebody with
enhanced senses being able to pick up on
the fact that they smell different they
can literally avoid any and all forms of
detection no one will ever know they're
an actual scroll and so in the end you
do have a ranking who basically tells
them when i was cast out right when i
was cast out and i was sent to that
desert world the empire continued to
limp wands which means i'm not really
needed here instead i'm needed on the
front lines i myself am going to go to
earth and when the question's asked what
physical form would you like to take she
chooses it but i'm not going to show you
guys what it is no spoilers down in the
comments section but i'm curious to see
if you can figure out what form varenke
takes which superhero does varenke
basically end up becoming in secret
invasion and i will say this it's
probably the person you would least
suspect but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace